Mark Zuckerberg is having a really bad
time right now Facebook is dying not
only is it losing popularity with young
people and becoming a place only for mom
and dads to argue over politics but
Apple completely wrecked Facebook's
biggest Money Maker by adding that ass
app not the track button this left a
really big multi-billion dollar debt in
their ads business Zuckerberg's personal
wealth has also taken a massive hits you
know how much money Warren Buffett has
yeah that's how much money Zuckerberg
lost since the start of 2022 and it's
all because of the metaverse
Zuckerberg is now dum dum he saw the
writing on the wall that Facebook's time
is almost up which is why he's been
dumping billions into his Visionary
project the metaverse 36 billion dollars
to be precise and he expects to invest
another 10 to 15 billion dollars more
every single year looking good okay no
not not really not really but even after
spending all this money on the metaverse
he's got nothing to show for us the
metaverse has become the world's biggest
money bits is this the end of Zuckerberg
and meta we'll get this guess what the
average lifespan of the 500 biggest most
successful corporations in America is
how long do you think these Mega
corporations last it's not a hundred
years it's not 50 years it's not even 25
years it's 21 years yes the average Mega
Corporation in America lasts only 21
years before getting knocked out of the
top 500 list and that lifespan is only
getting shorter and shorter and given
that Facebook is now 18 years old we
very well could be witnessing the end of
Zuckerberg's brain and the metaverse
might be the last nail in his coffin
stay dangerous subscribe for more and
let's get into it
[Music]
on this channel we try our best to break
through all the bias and fluff you see
in mainstream media to try to get closer
to the truth but quite frankly we can't
cover every single story out there which
is why you gotta check out ground news
ground news is the world's first news
comparison platform where every single
day ground news goes through 60 000 news
articles from over 50 000 different
sources then they take all these
different pieces and merge them into a
single story that gives you a variety of
perspectives all in one single place
that way you can see how different news
outlets are framing the same story you
can compare headlines and ground news
even gives you a visual breakdown of the
news sources for a story to see just how
biased the coverage for a story is you
can customize your own feed and they
even have a session called my news bias
where it tracks how many articles you
read where you're getting your news from
were the stories you read land on the
political spectrum and a ton of other
cool data ground news has been a game
changer for me it saves me a ton of
energy and gives me perspective on
current events that I would have never
had before I highly recommend you try
out for free by going to ground.new
slash jaketran or by subscribing to them
to get access to all the features we
over here that's ground.new jtran with
the link below thanks to ground news for
sponsoring this video
Mark Zuckerberg has had a problem even
though Facebook has been a massive
success it still isn't a core part of
the internet far from it actually
if you think of the internet as a super
highway Google and apple own the roads
and cars but Facebook Facebook is more
like a stop on the highway controlling a
single stop on the highway is not as
valuable as controlling the roads and
the cars themselves and on top of that
the stop on the highway that is Facebook
is not as popular as it once was today
most of us view it as a place reserved
only for our parents
by the time Facebook came into existence
the opportunity to control something
like a mainstream web browser or phones
had faded Google had already cemented
their throne with Android and chrome and
apple with their iPhones and iOS
ecosystem and it's not like Zuckerberg
isn't aware of this he's tried to carve
out a piece of the pie for himself
creating his own Facebook phone back in
2013 but to no avail Mark Zuckerberg has
had to accept the fact that he missed
the boat and now there's nothing he can
do about it with Facebook under decline
he knew if he didn't try something new
his Reign would soon be over and that's
when the light bulb went off
Zuckerberg noticed that every 15 years
or so a new technology emerges that
changes everything from personal
computers to the old Motorola brick
phones to the internet to smartphones
each one of these phases was more and
more immersive than the last and the
next phase of immersion according to
Zuckerberg its virtual reality and
augmented reality that you need to have
a technology that delivers this feeling
of presence right the sense that you're
actually right there with another person
and all the different Sensations that
come with that after all imagine a world
where you could connect your brain to a
computer and be teleported to a seamless
virtual reality that feels exactly like
the real thing except in this world all
your problems go away you can live
whatever life you want you can be
whatever you want without any effort you
can live out your wildest fantasies and
you wouldn't be limited by the shackles
of your human body given how many people
already try to escape the real world
with social media it's sad to say say
that almost everyone would sign up for
something like this in a heartbeat this
is the next phase of technology that
Zuckerberg wants total control over the
metaverse
scheming this for a while which is why
he bought our Oculus VR in 2014 but in
2021 Zuckerberg made it official and
announced that Facebook would be
completely rebranded to meta
his expectation is that in 10 years or
so people are going to be living in the
metaverse more than they do in the real
world and according to him they're even
gonna like it better than the real world
and this time Mark is doing everything
in his power to make sure that his
company is the one with the Monopoly
over the hardware and the software the
only problem is Mark just might be a
little bit too early
foreign
36 billion dollars and an ungodly amount
of man-hours at the problem Zuckerberg's
metaverse is lackluster to say the least
all he has to show for it is a bunch of
ancient looking Graphics buggy games and
subpart looking avatars with no legs and
even on their own app store their
metaverse app called Horizon worlds only
has a two-star rating
to be fair they have come up with some
good Innovations like being able to type
a text message with simple hand motions
or ways to create extremely
photorealistic avatars but it's far from
enough to dig Zuckerberg out of the hole
he's dug
Zuckerberg's own employees hate the
metaverse so much that he has to force
them to use it in a study of volunteers
using the metaverse for work for just
one week was full of reports of motion
sickness anxiety and poor productivity
some people even dropped out after just
two hours of trying and investors are
not impressed Zuckerberg announced the
Rebrand to meta in October of 2021. one
year later his stock is down over 70
percent that's a drop of over 700
billion dollars since the change and
very recently the company had to fire
over 11 000 employees to stop the
financial bleed of course just because
they're struggling right now and
everyone is giving them hate doesn't
mean the metaverse won't be a thing one
day Mark just might run out of money and
support before his vision of the
metaverse becomes a reality there's an
old saying quote you can always spot the
Pioneers by the arrows in their backs
end quote
but if Mark Zuckerberg does succeed
things would not look good for the rest
of us
[Music]
again people spending more of their time
in the metaverse than an actual reality
will probably be true someday no matter
how sad that may be the problem is if
one single Tech Giant like meta controls
both the hardware and the software for
the metaverse we're in big trouble think
about it the internet is already the
backbone of the world economy it's how
we Bank how we sell Goods sometimes it's
even how governments meet to write laws
we've already seen what Apple has been
willing to do to shake down companies on
the App Store and they're not even a
real Monopoly but the metaverse the
metaverse would be like that but for
everything you do every day your home
Computing system need access to the
metaverse to use it digital products you
bought there like avatar clothes music
and digital art you gotta buy it through
the metaverse work remotely you need
access to the metaverse to do your job
and this isn't an exaggeration meta is
already planning to charge up to 50 fees
for content created and sold through the
metaverse which means that anyone who
creates and sells in this virtual space
gets less than half of the money their
content made
no wonder Zuckerberg wants to metaverse
to be the one place everyone uses to
connect no wonder he predicts the
metaverse will be the home to a new
massive economy of digital art and
content creation if his company gets
half of all earnings across the entire
world's digital space it could be the
wealthiest Monopoly in human history
re-solidifying Zuckerberg's Throne on
the world stage but it doesn't stop at
just High fees a metaverse controlled by
one Tech Giant would be much darker than
that
[Music]
foreign
if it's true that one day we'll spend
more time on the metaverse than in real
life than the institution that controls
that reality that sets the rules that
tracks your each and every move that
monitors each and every transaction that
taxes you for every action you take will
be more powerful more all-encompassing
than any government before it not only
would they be able to do obvious stuff
like have social credit scores but they
would be able to do scary stuff like
track your every facial expression
through the headsets
the term metaverse was actually first
used in a science fiction novel called
snow crash and is in similar stories
like ready player one it's the kind of
story where the real world is so ruined
and miserable that nobody wants to live
in it so they just put on their VR
headsets and live in a virtual universe
that's basically run by Mafia style Tech
monopolies when Zuckerberg first bought
Oculus in 2014 he made the dystopian
science fiction bestseller Ready Player
One required reading
if you thought Facebook was evil it is
nothing compared to China's forced organ
harvesting business we would cover this
in a public video but talking about
forcibly removing the organs of
prisoners to sell the wealthy foreigners
is a little too grotesque and will
definitely get demonetized so we've
released it as a private documentary
uncensored available right now to
members of this Channel all you have to
do to watch it is hit that join button
below once you join you'll get access to
this and other documentaries that teach
you about how the world works but are a
bit too spicy to be covered on YouTube
members love these documentaries and you
will too plus there's a refund policy
too unlike most YouTube memberships so
if you join in you don't think it's
worth it email us within your first
month of joining for the first time and
we will personally refund you for your
first month after your first month there
is no refund so scroll down and click
that join button now
foreign
[Music]